well Iran has warned that Israel will
pay after a senior member of Iran's
revolutionary guard was killed in an air
strike in Syria razi musavi was killed
in the suburbs of the capital Damascus
he was considered a close Ally of
General kasum salamani the Revolutionary
guard commander who was killed in a US
drone attack in
2020 following M's killing supporters of
the Iranian government gathered in tan
calling for Revenge Israel has carried
out hundreds of strikes on targets
inside government controll parts of
Syria in recent
years well Ali Akbar Darin is a
researcher at the Journal of the center
for strategic studies in tan he joins us
from mhad thank you so much for being
with us on Alger first of all Iran as I
mentioned there has warned that Israel
quote will pay how s ious is that threat
and what sort of response do you think
we can
expect um there is no way that Iran is
not going to respond to this act of
terrorism killing an a top Iranian
General in a foreign land is a violation
of international law uh Israel has uh
has stepped one one uh move further uh
into uh the Red Zone it's it has crossed
the red line so Iran will retaliate but
how Iran is going to retaliate to this
assassination um is is not clear at this
point but uh what we can say with
certainty is that Iran will retaliate at
the time and place of its own choosing
it could be in uh in in in terms of
Iranian allies um uh attacking Israel it
could be uh an act uh of Revenge from
within Israel and it could be an Iranian
expansion of its nuclear program uh so
there is a number of options Iran has
but Iran is not going to show any
emotional reaction Iran's retaliation
will be based on calculations not
emotion okay can you just tell us a
little bit more about razi mavi and and
just how important a figure he was uh
within the Revolutionary
guard uh General musavi was a top figure
an influential figure in coordinating
Iran's Regional policy of creating a
strategic depth and that means he was a
an influential figure uh coordinating
Iran's efforts with General sanii and in
the post Suman era uh you know in being
involved in uh in uh actions that that
deter Israel and improve
Iran's Regional deterence policy uh he
was a key figure in uh in the war in
Syria in in in protecting uh president
Bashar al-assad's government and also uh
providing support to Iranian allies
including hisbah uh so he he his loss is
a big uh is a big uh you know harm for
Iran and Iran uh is making sure that uh
it will it will respond there is a
mounting pressure on the ri
Administration to react but Iran will
act based on very careful strategic
calculations but the big reason is yes
go oh no I was going to say you
mentioned the the pressure that's coming
uh on the on the government we've seen
protesters taking to the streets calling
for Revenge can you just give us a sense
of just how much Ang
there is
there uh what I see today uh is a repl
of the anger after uh after former US
president Donald Trump ordered the
assassination of General
sumani there is the same anger being
revived now so Iran cannot uh cannot
remain silent it has to take action to
deter Israel other wise Israel will will
go uh for more terrorism and and will be
more aggressive the the main reason for
Wars and conflicts in the Middle East is
the fact that there is no uh balance of
power uh Israel is equipped with nuclear
weapons it invades its neighbors without
fearing uh the uh the consequences or
without the fear of being punished uh in
the the same way this has led to Israeli
aggressions and uh but now the Iranian
uh decision makers uh are contemplating
on how to uh detain the rabid dog of the
middleast nanyu and his government by uh
by punishing Israel in a way that it's
not going to uh to repeat this act of
terrorism again okay thank you so much
for your your time and your inside that
is AK for
us you're welcome